when Gillian transferred to Hillsdale in
2006 she walked into our collegian
newsroom with the meekness of katy perry
not in volume she wasn't loud but she
was confident driven and eager to write
I was news editor brush off of an
internship in Washington DC under an
editor who made grown-ups cry and I
returned ready to kick my collegian
reporters into gear Gillian didn't need
any inspiring it's impossible to forget
the pink boa she occasionally war with
heels and jeans and a shirt but she wore
it like you're I would wear a polo
that's Gillian at the collegian while I
nudged most reporters I made attempts to
rain Gillian n even back then she loved
investigating investigative reporting
she wanted to unveil truth this is very
held alien she was in the right place
and right out of the gate Wyoming dirt
still on her shoes she was ready to
sniff out the secrets the deep throats
the skeletons of the college this was a
meshing so well my endeavor as an editor
to mend relationships with college
administrators that had been broken by
collegian editors before me the papers
reputation wasn't what it is now it is
excellent and I wanted to issue in a new
era of trust and professionalism Gillian
was part of that she became a leader at
the collegian too she's also part of a
new wave of successful journalists
bringing from Hillsdale and a leader of
the pack jillian is a bit intrepid rider
Charlie cook told me in September that
she got in touch a few years ago with
Christopher Hitchens the famous writer
and asked him to go to
with her in New York City and he did as
Charlie told me this is so Jillian and
it takes an intrepid person to travel
the world combat language barriers and
cultural barriers and danger and believe
there are stories to tell and that
you're the one who can find the truth
and tell them right this is what Jillian
does and this is why she is here tonight
and now for our official introduction I
met melter hello my name is Matt
Melchior I'm a marketing student here a
senior with a journalism minor to
complement that and this journalism
minor came to be I'm after seeing in
particular Hillsdale student Excel after
graduating hillsdale college and the
journalism program and we're lucky
enough to have her here tonight and I
particularly am excited this journalists
I feel like I've known her my whole life
and I would even go so far as to say
she's like family to me and the reason I
admire this journalist so much as she's
first in line of ten Melchior children
and she's also my dear sister that she
writes for National Review as a fellow
for the Franklin center and independent
women's forum tonight I have the
pleasure of introducing her her stories
remind me how fortunate I am to
introduce you're here tonight knowing
that she's safe perhaps after tonight
you'll understand why I've been at home
or heard the stories when she sells her
various escapades to my parents telling
them Oh it'll be fine it's safe I'm just
interviewing a few people nothing to
worry about however winter articles
surface and we read them it becomes
quite apparent that to be quite frank
she's in some pretty dangerous
situations reporting on some very
interesting things her investigative
reporting has a louder to report in
China Ukraine and most recently Iraq
tonight shall share her experiences from
Iraq and maybe give you a different
person
active on how devastating terrorism can
be because this talk is being broadcast
I will give the disclaimer that some of
the content is graphic in nature and
maybe not suitable to be broadcasted to
children however you all look like you
can handle this information in this room
without any more ladies and gentlemen
please help me in introducing and
welcoming miss Julian voucher good
evening some in an end game which is an
excellent history of the Iraq war
there's a story in it about how Ghazi
all you are the Sunni vice president in
2005 broke down into tears in a meeting
with general Casey and this book
describes that seen as an extraordinary
display of emotion for an Arab
politician but having reported in Iraq
I'm actually a little surprised it's not
more of a common reaction of all the
countries that I visited and all the
people i've talked to iraq is definitely
the most hopeless and depressing place
and that makes it a really interesting
place to write and to think about faith
because in this god forsaken land
religion is everything and i think
there's a tendency in iraq to view it as
just a place that's overrun by
overwhelmingly evil people and with the
Islamic state controlling so much
territory that's a hard impression to
argue with but what caught me by
surprise is that I met a lot of good
people to people who have perseverance
and a reluctant but strong and powerful
faith so and it's a mistake I think to
imagine Iraq's persecuted Christians and
uz DS and other religious minorities as
superhuman to put them on a pedestal I
think what kind of makes their faith so
special is that it's incredibly human
and if you put them on that pedestal it
undermines the humanity of their faith
and it D personalizes them in a way that
I think already happens a lot in Iraq so
it's a country where I think individuals
have lost their humanity to a great
extent already I mean these are people
who have been slaughtered
like animals their women have been
treated like property and they live in
cities of tents now as refugees and you
look at these tents it's just one after
another they live in fear of the colds
they live in fear of a fire starting at
one of the tents and spreading to the
others and if you look at that you're
just you're overwhelmed by the sense of
personal loss you're overwhelmed by the
capacity and in that I think people
become statistics rather than
individuals and that's an incredibly
dangerous thing when you're looking at
foreign policy I mean to be sure I Rex
an incredibly complicated place and it
requires complex policy complex moral
judgment but I'm not going to pretend to
be an expert on that I mean I spent ten
days there that is incidentally ate more
than Barack Obama spent when he ran for
president which I found kind of
interesting but through this speech I
don't want to win I don't want to win
you over to a policy point I want to
show you the fundamental humanity of the
Iraqis that I met there and tell you
some of their stories that moved me that
changed the way that I view it because
now when I think about Iraq way the
policy decisions I see these people's
faces and I know that they're decent
people there who are enduring incredible
stress enormous struggles and they're
doing it with dignity and with an
unlikely faith so for starters I think
we tend to view Iraq as a majority
Muslim country and it is but it's also a
very diverse place religiously so in
2003 Iraq was home to 1.4 million
Christians and between now and then
somewhere between a half and a third of
two-thirds rather have left and from
Mosul alone which is Iraq's second
largest city 600 or 6,000 people have
left just this last summer the first
Iraqi Christians that I met were part of
that population and there were people
who ran from the Islamic state sometimes
on foot carrying their children carrying
their elderly and on the scorching
September day that I met them first they
were living in this half built structure
and as some of you have probably watched
the show homeland they reminded me of
that if you know in season two there's
that big concrete structure that people
are living in it looks like that but
it's a little bit shorter so this
concrete floor is
spotted with foul-smelling puddles
refugees kind of strung up tarp to make
these makeshift rooms and there are
flies everywhere I mean I'm writing
things in my notebook as I'm
interviewing them and they're landing on
my pen they're landing on my face on my
hands and as I talk to people mothers
are saying you know I don't want to live
like this i have to go next door to wash
hands and i'm afraid for my children
because i know these conditions are
squalor so i know they're going to get
sick and children are everywhere I mean
Iraq has more children than any place
I've ever visited and as I talk to
refugees there and none of them could
remember the last time they'd even heard
the sound of silence the people that
lived in that building were the lucky
ones I met a newlywed man named Evan he
was an English teacher and he told me
that he couldn't sleep anymore because
of the sound of bombs in his head on the
day he left his city of care akash
august six a bomb had exploded and it
killed a woman in two young children and
he was near the explosion he heard it he
smelled it he felt the ground shake and
he says that when he closes his eyes at
night all he can think about is the site
of broken body is being taken to a
church next door he fled and what
happened next in care Akash is very
difficult to verify there have been
emailed chain letters circulating with
missionaries claiming that children were
being systematically be headed after
refusing to deny their faith now I tried
to verify that story I can't it seems to
me that it's pretty impossible to verify
reports I heard was that it was slightly
exaggerated but that at the same time
it's definitely within the realm of the
possible so people that I knew from kara
gosh when they left um they'd known a
man who was beheaded and then also seen
children seized being used as sex slaves
his child soldiers so those Christians
who've survived and escaped have
literally lost everything except for
their faith and their desperate to leave
Iraq Evan who's the man who witnessed
the bombing told me that in his three
decades alive he can't remember the last
time he experienced peace and then for
women the situation is even worse at
that same half-built structure I met a
22 year old woman named Sarah she was
from the town of Bart Ella outside of
muscle and the Islamic state had torn
down her church but first it burnt the
cross and she remembers looking at that
and just feeling hate and she can't help
it she's 22 years old she's just more
desolate and more hopeless than any
person I've ever met that age and she
tells me that's because she's a history
student she wants to be a lawyer at some
point but she's living in a country
where there are no rights for women and
where the situation's progressively
getting worse she can't see a future for
herself unless she leaves Iraq and
that's uncreate increasingly like
unlikely that that will happen so I want
to read you what she told me she said
I'm an Iraqi young girl from the time I
was born until now we've had no good
days we've had a bad past and we have a
bad future we lose our lives and then
she paused and looked at me and told me
something that I found just fascinating
she said religion is something that you
choose if you're free you choose it the
Islamic state people tell you you must
convert but people are free to choose
two things our honor and our religion
that choice is a difficult one I learned
this talking to Douglas bazi a priest he
was a tough guy he moved to unko off
from baghdad and in baghdad he'd been
shot in the leg he'd been kidnapped for
nine days and his church had survived
three explosions targeted at their
population when he began there there
were two thousand six hundred members of
his church when he left only 250 so in
other words this is a man who really
knows suffering nevertheless on the
surface when I met him he seemed jovial
he had just this excellent grasp of the
English language and a very generous
sense of humor 214 families more than
700 people were camping out on tints in
the churchyard of morelia and he wanted
to take care of them so in the night I
visited he was hosting a pageant for
them it's called it Murray Lea's got
talent and he'd stringed off rope to
make this makeshift stage he'd found
this old microphone in this rickety
projector
and he was talking people into sing
Kurdish folk songs kind of gently
coaxing them to the stage and he had a
piece of paper and a pen he holed up
ratings and then he'd give them these
grandiose critiques and all of the
refugees were wrapped this was the best
thing that had ever happened to them
they were mesmerised in for a minute
they forgot their suffering but father
Bobby hadn't forgotten his he actually
reminded me a lot of the whiskey priest
in graham greene's the power in the
glory I asked him whether he believed
having seen all he'd seen that God was
in control he wouldn't answer me that's
an interesting question he said write
that down and that was his only response
he told me he worries about the
practicality of saying jesus loves you
to a population where they have plenty
of children no blankets and a cold
winter fast approaching nonetheless he
told me if God works together for the
good of all things for those who love
him then it's my responsibility he said
to make sure that these Christians look
back on this time as an opportunity and
so as a priest he spent his time at
morelia churchyard focusing on education
developing rigorous opportunities for
these people and focusing especially on
educating young women which I find very
admirable he also told anyone who had
the opportunity to leave Iraq to go and
for those struggling with their faith
and stuck in Iraq I want to read you
what he said and that is that I tell
people that their current situation is
not because of what God did it's because
of what humans or politics did we belong
to God we don't belong to anyone else
God saved us in the past so let's
account for the same God because he's
going to save us but we have to put our
hearts with God and not with anyone else
as Jobe said why do we accept the good
things from God and not the bad it's not
only Christians who are being targeted
by the Islamic state though in fact if
we can describe unfettered brutality and
a level of degrees which is pretty
questionable to be honest the easy days
have had it or the Christians have had
it better than the Yazidi s which is
another ancient religion and that's
because while Isis views
Christianity is an offshoot of Islam if
used the yazidi faith is totally pagan
and separate and so it treats them with
even more unchecked fury the American
media learned about the plight of the
Yazidi is this August when the Islamic
state invaded their villages and drove
them up Mount Sinjar now when I talk
about Mount Sinjar I'm not talking about
a lush mountain with waterfalls in
foliage this is a you know the biblical
Jonah it's his Nineveh and being there
you kind of get a sense of why he was so
frustrated with God when God let the
only tree giving him shade wither away
to worms I mean this is a sparse
scorching barren treacherous place and
the fact that the easy saw this is a
preferable refuge says a lot about the
unchecked sadism of the Islamic state so
sources that I interviewed the Yazidi is
told me that as they were going up this
hill is Lama state was shooting into the
crowd and there were parents that had
more children more elderly than they
could carry and they had to make the
difficult decision about who to leave
behind and this woman saw wounded people
dying on the side of the road she sought
children who were abandoned out of
necessity that we're going to die of
thirst be attacked by animals or be
killed by the Islamic state atop that
mountain those who survived from those
who survives languish for more than a
week no food no water no shelter Islamic
state on three sides they were finally
rescued by the American airstrikes with
the trommel lingers and I learned this
when I met the coded kala family in the
town of bhadresh my guide had made
friends at them we went to bring them
bedding because before that the entire
family had been sleeping on a dirt floor
with one blanket the family'd always
been poor but you could tell from just
being in the room with them that they
had loved the father's name was his son
and he wanted me over right away he
showed me his arm he didn't ever ring on
his finger but he had a heart that he'd
gotten tattooed there and then when I
asked him what it was it was his wife's
name inside and she was so she Fishman
he told me that she giggled and it was
just really charming but their house if
you can call it that the place they were
living was no
her happy and that's because you know I
remember in this shelter counting six
children and except for the babies none
of them were normal boisterous kids they
weren't acting like children do they
were sitting there silence don't faced
and most straightening was Hassan's
daughter Claudia she was four years old
wild dark hair and these dark eyes so
angry so intense just staring at me and
when you looked away from her eyes you
could see her feet and her toenails were
completely shattered or missing and
that's from her time up on Sinjar
Mountain Hasan told me that Claudia seen
people die along the way Isis had
captured 20 women and girls and his
extended family they don't know what
happened to them Hasan told me that
eight men in his extended family had
also been killed and it bothered him
deeply that he knew their bodies were
still lying on the spots where they've
been butchered I know no one's there to
make a grave for them he told me Claudia
rarely speaks at four years old but
Hassan said that when she does she asks
when the Islamic state is going to come
kill them Hassan's family was not the
only one wrecked by tragedy in the town
of Sharia about an hour's drive north of
isis-held mazule I met a young woman
named damsah she was 19 years old she'd
been married that the love of her life a
man named Khalil they'd a two year old
son together who he adored and she was
four months pregnant with her second
child when the Islamic state came I'm
son Khalil tried to flee on foot but the
Islamic state caught up to them and when
it did it separated the men from the
women now I can't speak to what happened
in this situation but there have been
reports of meant being beheaded being
buried alive all I know is that all she
tells me that when she was separated she
heard a spate of gunshots and her heart
sank the Islamic state took her to a
warehouse in Mosul it has two round two
thousand women she estimates and all of
them were grieving she they told her
basically to convert or die
and she said that she kept her yazidi
faith in her head but she had to convert
so she pretended to after 10 days in
that warehouse they took her to a
smaller house nearby and it was just her
her two-year-old son and a bunch of
black dressed bearded jihad ease now
these men beat her they locked her in
her son in a room no food no water did
all this to coerce her into to sham
marriages and when she finally consented
they were angry that she'd held out that
long this woman is repeatedly raped
repeatedly beaten and I used to bring
her son in front of her hand him a giant
weapon and tell him that they were going
to train him to be just like they were
well finally they told I'm said that
they were going to take her to Syria
that they were going to make her be a
bride to even more jihadis and that was
the turning point for her she decided
that essentially even if she tried to
escape and diet that that would be no
less bad and probably better than what
they'd already done to her so she took
her two-year-old son in the middle of
the night and ran she wandered a long
time down a road and a kind Sunni man
saw her reluctantly she confessed her
story to him and he took compassion on
her he told her that's not what Islam
stands for we don't believe this he took
her into her house hit her along with
his family and they smuggled her to the
Kurdish border now when I talked to her
it was a few weeks after her escape her
bruises and started to fade but the
emotional trauma is there but at 19
years old I was impressed with her
strength she'd been through incredible
trauma that she wanted her short old to
the west and she told it in a voice that
was a little bit high a little bit quiet
but nonetheless strong until we brought
up the topic of her husband I wanted to
understand the relationship that they'd
had who he'd been before who she'd been
before this and she couldn't finish she
looked at me drew knees up to her chest
hit her face behind the veil and wet one
of her closest friends is there told me
that her husband was in his words more
awesome than she was and he clearly
adored her so we waited
we waited and finally he told me it's
just too painful in the name of religion
the Islamic state has captured many
women like arms as sex slaves I've seen
estimates ranging from between 1,000 to
7,000 women and in the islamic state's
official publication disturbingly
available in english dub you they
actually glorify slavery they say sexual
slavery is part of what they believe in
and something that necessitates are
their religion necessitates the islamic
state even encourages some of these
women to phone home telling them to
recount the horrors that they've endured
to their families i talked to one girl
who was 18 years old a high school
senior and she told me that she mourns
her cousin she knows a little bit about
what happened because an escaped woman
told her from a cell phone call this
woman's beaten and raped more routinely
than she's fed what she heard about her
cousin was that she prays that an
american air strike will kill her along
with the jihad ease now to be honest
remembering the painful stories of
iraq's believers it's really difficult
for me to draw the kind of sweeping and
big conclusions that make for a good
speech so from dr. Morrissey's class
actually i remember discussing just war
and about how a war not only needs to be
justifiable and good but in the national
interest and as I thought about Iraq
I've heard compelling arguments on both
sides about whether the initial war was
a just war or not leaving that aside I
want to say that it really morally
bothers me having seen these people but
the United States made a commitment to
them and then abandoned them I think
that left them essentially wide open to
this kind of horror and this becomes
more troubling now because I've seen
firsthand that in addition to fanatics
and terrorists and psychopaths Iraq has
a great share of good people moderate
Muslims Yazidis devout Christians people
who love their families who try to do
their best and who are suffering greatly
without any end in sight and without
seeing these individuals there's a
temptation to swear off Iraq to say this
is a godforsaken place that's never
going to be right let them kill each
other off
but for me I know that there will be
plenty of killing when the good perish I
think it's all the more fearsome to
consider who will remain thank you any
questions yeah people you spoke with
wrongs all hers were there some arrows
as well yeah actually they were good
amount um so I went to a church outside
in alcoa which um it's near it's kind of
near herbal and made a lot of sheer
refugees from sort of the sidelines that
had flood in with the Islamic state
there's actually a little girl she got
really attached to me really fast she
was following me all around for two
hours as i was doing interviews and we
decided we're going to interview her and
it was kind of the same thing as the
little girl with the broken toe nail is
that when we talked about the Islamic
state she'd seen the propaganda I mean
they're in such close quarters that kids
here adults talk and they really know
about what's going on what the
implications of that are and some of
them have seen that violence firsthand
and she was telling me that um it's just
like seven years old she's telling me
that she knows they'll kill kids and she
can't understand why and that that just
bothered her and her parents had a
similar reaction I mean they're Muslim
their Xie not Sunni but um you know they
were willing to go fight for it they
were concerned for their families I
think it's something that's had a pretty
profound effect across all of our rack
yep what kinds of opinions states
um to mainly i was in Kurdistan which is
pretty overwhelmingly pro-american so
one of the things I was by honey for my
mom when I travel because it's supposed
to taste different depending on the
region urine so into this honey store
it's one of the few like things for fun
I did there and the guy heard I was
American and he was just beside himself
pours me this big thing of honey Oh
America I love America I love your
airstrikes and then he goes tell Obama
hello for me tell him thank you so it
was pretty overwhelmingly pro-american
there the other thing I heard when I was
talking to UM shut the 19 year old girl
um the guy who did the translation for
that was not my normal fixed her it was
her close friend and he had been a
translator for the US Army his English
was phenomenal and it was good because
they had a trust relationship but he was
really anxious because he felt like he'd
given a lot to the American cause that
he'd believed in the democracy project
that he'd really put his life on the
line for it and that now not only were
they have sent but he had no out
I wish I knew some of them I don't I
didn't get to go to a Kurdish military
base so the situation with Kurdistan
it's Iraq but it's not which makes it a
little bit safer this is a really in
exact comparison but it's kind of like
how Hong Kong is a part of China but not
so it's it's own special administrative
region if you will it's got a government
but it's also it's kind of its on state
um so the Peshmerga fighters are pretty
much the only capable ones there when
the Iraqi army collapsed they defended
the line and they're very competent I
mean like I've stayed in touch with a
couple of them on Facebook and it's been
really interesting to see their
observations about it um the thing that
was really interesting to me we talked
to this commander who is related to the
Kurdish president he's the nephew I
think and he was saying that even for
his soldiers the psychological warfare
has been a huge huge impactful Famer for
them that because men have seen what
happens to women and children who are
left behind that they're always going to
have that in the back of their head when
they leave to fight and that makes them
a little bit less bold and he was saying
that that's something that's been a huge
problem in addition to how dirty the
Islamic state fights in addition to the
bombings that that was one of the things
he identified his crucial problem he
seemed to think that American airstrikes
could hold the line in Kurdistan that it
wouldn't be enough to knock out the
Islamic state as a whole um on top of
that I I guess I didn't meet me
Americans that had gone there but
they're definitely outnumbered their
fierce punch a lot of them have bought
their own weapons it's illegal to buy
guns and Kurdistan they shut that down
and these have an old gun bizarre I'm
really sad i missed it by a couple weeks
and i hear that part of the reit i don't
know if this is true but i hear that
part of the reason that they shut it
down was because they do international I
guess armaments we're going to be coming
in and they were afraid of it being
detected or making its way to the black
market
getting caught for it essentially but a
lot of these people have bought their
own bulletproof vests their own boots
we're doing with their own funds
um well I think a lot of it tends to
cover the big picture and that's as it
should be but I kind of hoped to tell
the story of people that didn't have a
voice and to talk about the innocence
and also to put a human face on it like
Wars a really big abstract thing but it
does affect individual lives I feel like
that's got to be part of the calculation
and it's also important to me when I do
foreign correspondents to feel like
there is a good guy in some respect or
at least a moral caught like it's not
just completely CD and corrupt and
decrepit and for me with the Christian
connection and what the easies in
particular I felt like that was
something that in a way my reporting
could get behind or support or given you
insight into what
it's pretty hopeless um people I talk to
their don't have high expectations I
think right now they're thinking that
they can hold the line at Kurdistan and
keep that safe but um I mean they feel
that from a military standpoint
airstrikes are going to be enough to
maybe keep them at bay for a while
they've already seen the Islamic state
change strategy to cope with the
airstrikes and get around it and also
they're afraid because their military
fell apart they're afraid because when
the Islamic state took cities it also
took American armaments so it's got some
really high tech beefy equipment um so I
mean it's rough to say I kind of agree
with them right now maybe the situation
will change but it does look pretty
bleak and it looks like not a lot of
people in the international community
want to stick it out want to eliminate
our the Islamic state from Iraq or Syria
and I mean it was an entrenched
engagement but I do think it will take
international forces to knock them out a
lot of military aid did you run into any
other like international goodwill for
the people
yeah we went to a UN run refugee camp um
which was really interesting and
strangely like hopeful I mean it was an
awful place like they were telling me
about how afraid they were of it in the
winter fire would start and it would
spread across that hadn't happened in
their camp but in another camp but had
happened and a woman and her family died
in it so that was something that was a
lot of anxiety but I think what was
interesting for me there was it was a
lot of Syrian refugees and they got on
with life like I met this boy who is
probably 17 or 18 years old he'd figured
out that there was a market for a
clothes in there and so he'd go into
town by like five or six items of
clothes figure out what things were
needed borrowed some money from his
brother and within about a year he'd
built it into this clothing business
inside the refugee camp know another
thing was really interesting was i guess
in the Kurdish part like social norms
are a little bit more relaxed and so
people from across Syria or Syrian and
Iraqi refugees were meeting each other
socializing getting married my tour
guide had just been married a week
before and it was somebody she never
would have met had she not been in this
refugee camp they had weddings there
they had a band that was like the local
band um so it was kind of on one
situation like you can look at it and
just think it's a terrible terrible
situation which it definitely is but I
was impressed with the resourcefulness
and spunk of the people there like they
were just really great and I think
international he'd helped that to some
extent but a lot of it was just their
strength of spirit anybody else oh yeah
whence they
um I think it's there the more I read up
on Iraq but you definitely see that
there are sectarian tensions that are
going to be pretty insurmountable um I'm
skeptical that they'll be able to
overcome them the Kurdish part is a bit
better I knew both she and Sunni Muslims
there who were tolerant of other points
of view tolerant of each other I just
wanted to have a functional country but
it's also difficult because people in
Iraq feel like it's an arbitrarily drawn
country kind of just jumbled together
and they're more loyal to their animus
being in generalities not for everybody
but um I think they're more loyal as a
whole to their particular sectarian
group brother religious affiliation and
it's hard to clump them together in a
country and make it function and they're
not sure what to do about it i'm not
sure what to do about it alright